take a trip on Oscar and you'll discover
the joy of slow motion top speed seven
knots about 12 kilometers an hour
- could also be at the helm of a big
boat a few years ago he got his master's
certificate as a boatman on inland
waterways water is important to him
it's been fun hats and gathered I love
being a dis burger I was born here I
went swimming in the Rhine
canoeing on the war and I find Duisburg
interesting because it has this close
connection to the water to the war to
the Rhine into the canals so of course
partly is port photographer I'm glad to
be able to show you three lovely places
everyone should visit in this book this
way you'll see it's worth it four hoofs
first tip busca has to be securely
moored we're going ashore in Deus bogs
Inner Harbor and suddenly you might
think we were standing among ruins but
this is art as a photographer wife
captain has an eye for the beauty of
places like this it's a memorial park
known as the Garden of Remembrance
created in 1999 by Israeli landscape
artist Danny Caravan it has a very
specific purpose to capture the memories
of a time when this part of the port was
still busy with activity a poetic
tribute to the past - god I think the
Garden of Remembrance is a beautiful
elegant park it's a reminder of the
history of this spot which was always
linked to shipping that's what the wave
symbolizes because this is where the
goods were loaded and unloaded grain was
trans shipped here and we see the ground
plans and fragments of buildings that
remind us of the time when this was a
bustling port and a hostile influx that
fund we now have a good hour on the
water ahead of us Oscar chugs through
the Inner Harbor towards his great
moment
entering the Rhine and suddenly we're
not alone anymore but our captain
remains relaxed in any situation
our next stop is on our forward
starboard side the point where the Ruhr
flows into the rhine it's a day trip
destination that's also reachable by car
but it's much nicer by boat
recommendation number two is Pont VAD
Peninsula
and if it's Adela we're now sitting at
the tip of Pont red peninsula we have a
great view of the Rua and the Rhine and
of the ships when there's a lot of
traffic
the Ryan is Europe's largest waterway
there's a lot to see many juice burgers
come here with their dogs
take a walk ride bicycles I've even seen
people having barbecues no wonder this
place is unique and it's just the right
place on a hot summer's day almost a bit
like being at the seaside we've been on
the go for a few hours now and we're
getting a little hungry
the wife cuppin has an idea we cross
over to the other bank of the Rhine and
we're at tip number three the spikey
restaurant wife has reserved a Riverside
table Deborah Finland's dirac hi we're
right on the banks of the Rhine we have
a beautiful view of the Rhine the ships
and all the greenery we have in Duisburg
the sun is shining on special days I
enjoy a good glass of wine here and feel
really comfortable
Duisburg is actually known as a
beer-drinking city and there really is
beer everywhere good wine is more of a
rarity but the spatula fills that
culinary gap and offers fine wines to
accompany equally fine and moderately
priced meals it's a delightful ending to
a summer day in Duisburg